yeah so pretty girls hit their wall
later do you guys know what the wall is
it's when you start
so so the wall are it's basically as
women our primary
primary agency is our sexuality and how
good we look that's why when you see
women protest something what do they do
they take off their clothes like every
single time [ __ ] march
like
it's because it's the best way to get
attention
if a pretty girl says something she gets
ten times the amount of attention if an
ugly girl says it's not it's not fun
it's just you know reality
but basically
between the we live to be 90 and between
the ages of 18 and 28 that's when like
we're the most attractive that's when
we're at our peak
and
a lot of times what'll happen is when
girls realize like their looks are going
they do things to get attention last
minute because it's like it's the end of
the party the lights are the lights are
going off and it's typically around 18
to 28 for like the average girl but if
you're
if you're this year it's like eight nine
or ten it's delayed a little bit for her
yeah
um and so this is her last hurrah yeah
so it's not an age but it's a mindset
it's a subconscious acknowledgement that
she cannot compete in the same way she
did when she was younger so it's not
necessarily always physical but mental
it's like
when you hit 30
when you hit 30 50 of your options are
gone on dating apps
so question do you think this is the
same for obviously we've spoken about
high value men
but you think this is the same for high
value women there's no such thing as a
high value no only high value women can
only men have to pick a high value man
has to pick a high value woman i don't
think that's true well then what is a
high value woman i know someone who's a
high value woman who i can't really say
names
whatever
okay so she's high value because she
as much as she's a mother she has
children
she has multiple businesses
she um is doing really really well in
her career men don't care is she married
she's not married but she's in a serious
relationship okay so she's in a
relationship she can't get a ring why if
she's a high value woman what do you
mean why can't she get around she's on
the way to get in the ring so she's does
she have a ring engaged she's
not engaged but she's in a relationship
they're comfortable they're happy yeah
they've been together
yeah but that i can't say
yeah you can't i don't know i don't know
how long they've been oh you don't know
yeah years months i think it's years
yes they should have been married
already if she's a high value woman if a
man has a high value woman he's not
taking years to comfort her wait you're
saying that there is no not taking years
because when you guys spoke about high
value
your description was someone who earns
10k a month and they've been doing that
for a man for a man
not for a woman what do you mean for a
man so a woman that earns 10k no that's
not high value so it's not high value
because men do not because men because
men do not
care about a woman's finances as a
matter of fact
do you know you know the footballer
ronaldo
yeah his wife used to work at um
some shop some she was a reta she was
worked in retail yeah now she's his wife
this is what high value men do they look
for the characteristics of a quote
because people would have said she's a
retail woman no she was a high value
woman that's why i married her because
he saw the qualities and and the things
that he needed in her wife in her and he
said yep that one so a high value woman
isn't necessarily somebody who makes a
lot of money a high value woman is down
to the qualities as a woman okay so tell
me exactly what a high value woman is so
if i was if i was to ever describe
someone a woman that could
possibly be high value i'd say someone
that can organize my my life
someone that is submissive towards me
someone that is cooperative someone that
can be a good mother can be a good
mother under 150 um someone that stays
in shape
pounds i don't know what you guys have
here yeah yeah
i'm under maybe like in shape so under
150 pounds a certain way you don't have
like my point is all the things i've
listed have nothing to do with what
you've just said okay so but like what
you're describing is what you would want
in a man yeah so
so wait let me explain so all the
characteristics that you've listed
that woman has
it's what she
wants in her ideal husband
a great career
money money yeah
um money power respect money power
respect she's at a high status in her
career she's doing really well for
herself
men don't care about becoming
the husband yes she wants to have
correct okay so
and you see the children that she says
she's got is it for him and high value
the closest thing to high value women
they get swooped up immediately that's
what i'm saying they're
gone
what am i doing waiting around why i'm
confused is because
so obviously like you guys described a
man as high value i heard 10k a month
and been doing it for x amount of years
right
so
if a woman is also doing that for x
amount of years and is desired by men
then what does that make her because a
woman's money doesn't make her desirable
to men but it's not about her money
they're not desiring her because of her
money all the other things that you
describe someone that can organize your
life someone that can be submissive that
some someone that can be caring all of
that be a great mother she's also that
too but just because she earns the money
makes her not high value no no it's
nothing so
so okay a girl's money is like a shoe
collection
so if we meet a guy we like him and he
has a shoe collection we're like oh
that's cool but we're not a trap we're
not like oh damn that shoe collection
like we don't care
and and so it's just there so if she's
fit feminine friendly and has those
qualities she probably would have a ring
so something's probably missing do you
think as well sometimes men try to marry
their mothers three hundred percent
because that's yeah possibly always like
it's freddie and isn't it yeah young
girl do you not feel weird about that
no because women try to marry their
fathers essentially too yeah
it's like
i think
i was like
sorry no but
the thing is a lot of time i don't think
it's conscious it's a subconscious thing
it's a freudian thing it's like traits
that your father wants yeah it's like
those traits that you think okay my dad
had these good traits my mom had these
good traits i want to kind of go for a
woman or a man who kind of has the same
thing i don't think it's like
i don't think it's i think it's normal
for people to do that if i'm talking
another thing as well i feel like with
certain relationships they fail because
they don't understand what marriage or
certain relationships are and how
they're supposed to work
because it's like you said you're that's
a woman that's submissive
but then
what would you do for her
to also
what that okay let's say this like
in the morning she makes you coffee
every morning she makes you coffee
before you go to work
now between the time you've gone to work
and come back what will you do for her
to encourage her to keep waking up in
the morning to want to do that for you
security
does it provide
understanding you can provide but after
a while should be like
i need yeah i don't know understanding
there's a lot of yeah like we said
earlier on you're getting 20k a month
what are you saying
if a man's giving you 20k a month that
we need to outline that early though i
think in any relationship you outline
early what your expectations are what
the goals of the relationship are
because if you're looking for different
things then there's no point you know i
mean if you so my example would be if i
want children and the man i'm with
doesn't want children why am i here yeah
if the man who i'm with wants to achieve
this thing say like a business or
something and i'm saying well i'm not
really about that and i'm not really
interested why am i here my job as a
woman it should
not my job but my duty as a partner
should be to support my partner
and when he runs out of steam kind of
sorry
we're not talking to them my voice
annoys me but
yeah well um so as i yeah but we can't
hear you yeah
so as a partner um
you know support that and kind of push
for what's good for him to reach those
goals because when a man feels respected
he'll give you love